they'll say hey you know what crime is a  serious problem but we don't want  prisons right that's what the left says  how about we give people a brain a  neural link that disables criminal  Behavior oh didn't they also say they  could put people on neural link and put  them in prison for like a hundred years  or something so they could experience  100 years wow that was a movie no no no  no that was also some conversations  actually having that conversation like  that could be the future of Prisons oh  man you go insane oh yeah it would be  like the blink of an eye but for you  it's 100 years you'd come out just go  like solitary confine it for 100 years  and you can't die you can't hurt  yourself like yeah that's torture it's  beyond torture that's crazy that's like  sending someone to Hell literally yeah  literally 100 years which is the goal  anyway